bonjour ça va
bravo ça cool
je vais vous parler
de ce qui est écrit en arrière de moi
savez vous ce qui augmente le taux de
dopamine qui régularise votre système
nerveux qui vous donne une énergie plus
de patience qui vous donne plus de signe
de confiance en vous ce qui libère un
peu plus d'oxydation dans votre cerveau
ce qui évidemment participent aux
voleurs c'est l'appel mais l'eau
disponible chez jean coutu
évidemment non mais c'est le câlin
qu'alain fatou sow j'ai fait des études
je vais vérifier sur des sites internet
très crédible évidemment et ça fait tout
seul et câlins je trouve ça fantastique
mais pourquoi je fais des câlins qui
pour quoi que depuis environ un an pour
faire un an le ca fais tu du vaima
entendez-vous devant vous ok parfait
c'est juste maison
le 11 mars prochain on va faire un an
que je devenu un monsieur carrez
pourquoi moi vous donner je vous donnais
les choix de réponse au quai
à cause de vladimir poutine
voyez ces sympathiques le monsieur on me
dit pas mourir ou encore de ces
magnifiques filles regardez comme ils
sont magnifiques c'est les miens
et
à cause de stéphanie son gant
philippe jean ali ou surtout à cause des
puces en tout cas je sais pas trop
j'avais le choix de trois réponses je
vous laisserai pas répondre en revenir
en valais on n'y peut rien c'est grâce à
m
mais c'est à cause de lui
vous allez me dire qu'est ce que
vladimir poutine faire à mon enfant
rappelez vous il ya un an pratiquement
jour pour jour qu'est ce que de se
défendre notre mivelaz d' il ya envahi
un pays
évidemment super sympathiques comme
personnage et comme décision et je me
suis levé
de mon vivant je me suis dit hé bah ce
monsieur là ayant cruellement manqué
d'affection dans sa tendre jeunesse ça
se peut pas que ce soit devenu comme ça
et prendre de telles décisions sans qui
a eu une lacune quelconque tu freud
entre howard qui
voyez que sa mère et lui on l'a très
heureux dans sa jeunesse fait que
probablement que ça peut ressembler mais
tout ça pour dire que ça ça a été comme
l'étincelle du vase la pohdh que fait
déborder la boîte à surprises et que je
me suis dit je vais aller en russie je
vois les délinquants mais non je réponds
en russie on s'entend que je parlais pas
les moyens j'ai pas le temps qui paraît
pourtant j'ai pas le temps en fait j'ai
pas envie d'aller en russie pour donner
un câlin à vlad parce qu'on s'appelle
vlad
anecdotes et quoi sérieux l'as mon
téléphone vous avez un numéro sept
semaines break m'a appelé c'est +7 7 2
caps quelque chose je vois fouillé sur
we first look up c'est un numéro de la
russie est quelqu'un ne réussit qu'à
celles appelées à voyage le ch'ti ça y
est vous l'a dit au courant
est temps qu'il faudra
donc j'ai décidé de donner des câlins
mais le monde quoique sa sortie que sa
pop et câlins j'ouvre ma deuxième
parenthèses la truie un mouvement de 5g
move qui serait mise en scène
parce que je connaissais le mouvement
free rogge
petit monde connaît le mouvement free
rock là on s'en va dans les places
publiques dans les grandes villes qui
ont marc-alain gratuits freerolls
taille vous connaissez pas
presque société inventé en 2004 par un
jeune australien qui a fait ça dans un
centre d'achat à sydney ça fait de la
mare de sang dans son édito besoin
d'avoir une police d'assurance
responsabilité civile de 25 millions ils
ont ramassé une pétition 10000 non c'est
à tomber à l'eau il a fait un petit film
en 2006 j'ai mis ça sur youtube bon
67 millions de visionnements et
aujourd'hui on fait des fruits est
partout dans le monde tac elle fait
attention suis au top de sa donne tout
son dauphin
donc je connaissais un peu le mouvement
je me suis dit bon je peux pas aller à
l'autre bout du monde mais je peux
participer quelque part c'est un geste
qui 5 qui est accessible et qui
évidemment
gratuit je peux faire sur moi je peux
participer à faire en sorte de donner un
petit peu plus ou de recevoir et de
partager la barre des 1 2 on en public
non les plus grandes capitales mondiales
on est juste le centre de l'univers
c'est un autre temps autre concept que
c'est pas tout le monde qui sont
nécessairement d'accord mais survient on
n'est pas toujours d'accord actuellement
ceci étant dit donc je me mets un enfant
dit qu'alain parce que je trouve ça beau
je trouve ça le fun oui faites le
évidemment j'ai contaminés premièrement
mes enfants
j'ai contaminer mon gazon mais j'ai pas
de gazon chez nous c'est à peu près
comme stéphanie ans que je t'avoue est
en train de le faire mourir j'ai pas
encore réussi mais ça donne les
situations et voyons si
ça donne en fait
un geste 5 en garde au
j'ai plein de choses à dire je veux le
chrono il me reste huit minutes je
capote j'ai osé faire un changement dans
mon moi j'ai découvert un mois -
m'emmener j'ai découvert que j'avais un
dedans il ya quelques années et j'ai
décidé de mon dedans de faire du
changement j'ai osé le risque savez vous
que mouss fait du kali nages ce coin là
rue gamble principal ici sauf depuis
trop au monde devrait comprendre que j'y
réponds que j'ai le cul à -40 la
suite quelle image ce qu'on a réussi
c'est quand même un risque pour un
risque que le monde rentre dedans mais
reste on vit pas dans une métropole les
gens que je vois croisé juristes les
recroiser à l'épicerie au départ en quoi
que ce soit
j'ai composé le risque parce que on
s'expose quand confesseur le jugement on
en fait tous vous êtes en train de me
juger présentement ce bon la tuque qui
dépasse ma chemise qui est peut-être pas
d'arêtes etc ont fait sont
inconsciemment on subit tout si on fait
tous du jugement fait que je risque je
risquais ça je vous je vais vous dire ce
que j'ai déjà entendu à mon sujet
peut-être que vous êtes capable
l'imaginez vous même j'ai aussi aux lots
danse un brin courage et surtout un brin
de folie
clin d'oeil et mélanie merci
parce qu'il faut faire si tu fais
toujours les mêmes affaires soient
toujours à savoir les mêmes résultats et
je me dis que le callet qui participent
au bonheur
on l'a vu tantôt participe au bonheur
qu'elle balance à celui ça se construit
mais si tu te balance le partage peut on
mourir avec ses poches
ces peurs savoir du bonhomme dans ton
étoile qui devant le partage était
apparenté enfin c'est cool des enfants
parfaits je les aime mes fils je trouve
météo je me suis dit que je pourrais
aller plus loin que juste mes enfants ça
évidemment je voudrais pas tout
s'équilibre mais c'est du monde
tout ce que ça prend pour un carré ça
vous c'est quoi
prend de gros
bras et c'est bon ça merci j'avais pas
vu de même medef chang hwan chase
brotchi j'en verrai plus jamais les
vidéos de chase bras la même façon
donc le câlin c'est juste un geste
bourbon hockey et j'aimais personnes qui
vont vendre tout et je veux pas gâcher à
face moi de donner un câlin non ça
marche pas demain le câlin c'est beau
c'est bon c'est juste du bon pied bon
c'est parfait c'est parfait le câlin
pourquoi c'est parfait
parce que tu peux pas donner plus que
sur soi
un secteur c'est une statue politiques
sociales économiques que ce soit grain -
grain plus petit gros plus maigre café
tout est dans la gueule ou aucune que tu
sens bon que tu penses que tu sens le
bon parce que tu t'es mis trop de
parfums qui te promènes en béquilles ou
en chaise roulante ça ça rien de moins
c'est hyper équitable parce que tout le
monde kata et 2 1
179 millions d'années ça changera rien à
moins que tu as deux groupes humains on
peut s'organiser et en ajustant on va
s'organiser ces tarifs sont fixés le
geste parfait pour moi je me dis le
geste parfait faut que ça se donne il
faut que ça se partage avec avec tout le
monde je me dis souvent que c'est
extrêmement un colon ceux qui me
connaissent un petit côté écolo parce
qu'il donne en salle et aucun
environnement se faire et en plus c'est
cesser renouvelables
et donc c'est symbolise le développement
durable c'est ça dure écoute j'ai fait à
peu près parce que la question qu'on
pensait qu'on mette en affaire je situe
exactement à calais
mais j'ai évolué grosso modo à peu près
3000 depuis grosso modo à peu près trop
mais c'est peut-être de 1800
à peu près 3 mai fait qu entre eux mais
je n'ai vécu tu sors et je vais quand
même vous prendre le temps de prendre
quelques anecdotes la première scène
coupe des semaines je t'ai pas encore
installé officiellement au coin d'un
zinc un buzz j'étais au coin principal
verrou évoluer mon doux
et là il ya monsieur angers jean 70 plus
il vient sur six ans qu'alain je donne
juin nous donne des vrai qu'à l'endroit
c'est quoi un vrai qu'alain je donnais
vrai qu'alain et cantiques ans qui se
dégage comme
ça parce qu'on se prépare à donner 1
sauf que je mettais comme mal préparés à
recevoir puis ça rentre dedans dès fois
que ce problème c'est que sa voix douce
et si juste que je ne me rappelle plus
en quelle année la dernière fois qu'une
personne qui m'a pris dans ses bras
c'est un étranger je connais pas ce
monsieur là la ministre a notamment
donné et tourner le coin de la rue ici
je te soutiens de la banque un genre de
fb mais 550 c'est pas drôle jack your
mind marqué harley davidson si leur
secret le gars qui veut la loi 4 où
seront les impeccables
et le iie sommet de la grille tout cela
qu'elles sont trois jeux rouille
et j'ai toujours même c'est pas quoi
faire un tour grande les collègues je ne
parle qu'avec ce jeudi
c'est grave c'est moins
bien sûr buts à une longueur en mariage
et une incarnation
mais non il s'en vient contrairement aux
textes gros bras google a subi des
brimades des fouilles fort hier par en
centrant qui dit merci a besoin est ça
ok
une dernière s'est amené ça sera quoi la
lumière ici la lumière rouge
le taux arrête la france souffre le
gosse je le connais il me dit un jeu
fait un câlin maurice monge dans le pas
de calais distance par ton auto vient me
voir prend 30 secondes ce n'est pas le
temps j'ai justement pour les gens qui
ont pas le temps que je fais ça fait que
pendant que je suis son fils ado 14-15
pas trop
y donne un gros câlin seront pas la berd
dans le sens réel sa lumière rouge
il s'en veut d'avoir dit merci morice
lumière tombe verte qui s'envolent
d'envoi deux mois après je prends un
café son terrain ce parce que je dois
dire que je prenne bien mais je prends
un café sont terrasse et il me dit
maurice merci ça faisait probablement un
un constat pas pris dans l'ombre au
plomb le fait trois fois par semaine ou
à peu près j'aime pas
oui tant mieux fait leur dise c'est
juste bon en fait puis je veux je veux
je voyais l'équipe sanli mohcine fin
l'analogie du pissenlit qui une analogie
là le bonheur c'est du gazon clip senlis
et des petits moments - phong moi j'y
vois une entreprise de gazaupouy
tacleur on peut même chimique le plus de
sites en partie siennes faire semblant
que le gazon impose plus vite puis quel
malheur disparaît plus vite si
artificielle ou stoked arrête sa tombe
une façon naturelle évidemment c'est
d'entreprise en argent de façon jeu
c'est normal et qui vient seulement de
l'erreur il monta luttant pas de faire
les femmes en général fait qu' il ya
comme un troisième niveau si on ne
serait pas injuste d'augmenter le seuil
de tolérance aux pissenlits dans notre
gazon testud grande synthe quatre cinq
six sept ou je sais pas quoi pourquoi
ils commencent à allumer ses rouges
fac e bonds l'expérimenté vais vous
devez vous vous allez le faire et que
vous en sortirez poste boulette vais
vous aimez et whaou fait pas de câlins
je vais vous dire qu'un mec en face au
mans vous dire il ya des règles et ces
3000 qu'alain d'expérience dans le bus
dont le safran deux groupes relativement
mou
pasqua relaxé ce jeudi là il faut
vraiment venir coller sur une chaise
puisque usées mesdames aussi vous avez
une anatomie mais reste que bon on se
consulte pièces comme faut on va
inspirer ensemble qui expirait ensemble
j'allais faire deux fois par sa première
fois ça y est tu reproches la deuxième
phase avec maya j'ai besoin d'une
volonté
donc à gauche on enclenche poisson fait
in out on est près de toi
deuxième fois enfin gare
merci tout le monde quand cela vous
donner des gages